I wouldn't bring Joel Kim booster on.
Joel, how are you staged like acting?
Oh, I'm great Moses.
I'm doing so fantastic.
Isn't it funny?
Though winding road that
life can take you on.
Last year at this time, you
and I were getting ready
to star in a Network Sitcom.
And now we're both unemployed
in the middle of a pandemic.
Isn't life funny?
How far the great fall?
(roughing) I keep in
touch because when we were
on NBC's least watch
Sitcom last year together.
Not this last year of all time.
Of all time.
Oh wow, I was trying to
feel worse than you did it.
It's called the sunny side,
but obviously people probably
know you too from shrill
that's Hulu and the new
season search party,
which is on HBO max or friends over there.
We were on, arguably the
biggest job that we've had.
Right?
Yeah.
Let me be clear a fun job.
Very fun, everyone's great job.
Yeah.
Lucky, lucky.
We're lucky.
Well, I wanted to die too
because everyone got mad
this weekend because a lot of people went
to Fire Island, right?
And I didn't know how
important Fire Island was
to the community.
And I say that 'cause I'm an ally,
until last year, right to
get out of the table raid,
because you wanted to
attend the Fire Island.
Yeah, I had a vacation
to attend to, and listen.
The biggest jo of your life,
t's the most corporate job
that you and I have ever had.
That's like.
Like suits and like,
you have to be here high
pressure, and you're like,
can I go park?
Yeah, and listen, you do you
don't know if you don't ask.
And did I get to do both things?
Yes.
You made it in the nick of time.
I think I arrived about five minutes early
for the table read.
Five minutes early, it's
very comforting to have all
these executives five minutes early.
Shown was early on, and it
turns out they were the boss.
They were the boss.
They ultimately said no, and
know we're afraid to party
as much as we want.
Exactly.
Did you have any friends
that went out to Fire Island?
Not this year, I will say like
it's obviously ridiculous,
to party in that way during the middle
of a pandemic and I do not condone it.
And I think it's awful.
I will say the discourse
around it is a little annoying
though because I will say
that's just what Florida
is doing every day.
Yeah
But because it's gay dudes,
like it's a unique story.
I don't know.
So like I'm not trying to defend them.
They should all burn
in hell, which we will
because we're gay.
It does seem a little bit
like, it's certainly not unique
to our community.
Yeah, so I've been pretty monogamous.
So what is dating look
like pretty monogamous
sounds like gross?
But what is dating looking
like during the pandemic?
Like if you're on the apps,
is there a second conversation
that needs to be heard.
I haven't like super weighted into dating.
Yeah, I mean I've been
doing a ton of sexting.
Just finding new crevices of my own body
to send out over the internet
that will surely ruin
my career later down.
Whatever is left of it after the pandemic.
This is the time to do it.
Just definitely discovering new parts
of my body, new angles.
What lighting can do for your penis?
All your penis.
Yeah, Just a little tiny one.
This is what I've got a little
baby light for my penuts.
It's a gross light for,
It should be 'cause you should have like
barely be able to see it.
But the ring light puts in
dentistry like every crevice.
So are not doing anything, no dating?
Not dating, just sexing.
There've been a couple
of people that like,
we've had the conversation
of like we should go
and get tested, and then
once we've quarantined
for a certain, but like you
get to that conversation
and then it just all seems so exhausting.
And so you just jerk off instead.
It makes it so unsexy when it's like,
do you have any ham
virus and killing people?
How long have you been?
When was the last time
you went to the store?
While, it's not allowed.
So many people it's
like, okay would I like
to hook up with Joel or
be able to hug my mother.
Yeah.
And so sort of the choices
for sure to put on me.
That's a lot of pressure
to put on yourself.
It doesn't seem worth it.
But an honor to even be
nominated in that conversation.
Yes, yes.
So you have a.
A little game.
So you know I'm adopted, fun
fact about me my birth name,
my Korean name is Kim Jong-Un.
And might know.
So, Koreans but we put the surname first,
and I share my last name
with a very famous Kim
that's right Kim Jong-Un,
fame leader of North Korea.
And what we're going to be
doing today is a little game
that I call a Kim Jong-Un,
or Kim Jong-Un man.
Yeah.
And what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna read
a YouTube comment to you
and you have to guess
if that is a YouTube comment
from one of my standup clips
that you might've seen
on Conant for instance.
Or a YouTube comment on a video
of Kim Jong-Un man riding a horse, okay?
Okay.
Specifically him riding a horse.
Specifically riding a horse.
And it might seem obvious at first
but there are some real
tricky ones in here.
So here we go.
So this one is from Bob
cam brutal knowledge,
unfunny narcissistic Asian
sodomite with an complex.
What do you think that is?
Is that me or is that Kim Jong-Un, Moses?
I'm gonna with you.
Okay, that is me.
That is one of mine.
I have to say polling
comments for this game
was psychologically damaging.
(chuckles)
This is from Dudley Do-Right RIT.
Less there be any confusion.
Forgive me on this one folks,
but I find this hilarious.
Forgive me, okay.
I always hate those on
standout if that's what it is.
I actually laughed at this.
I have a little trouble, I'm gonna go
to the chat for this one.
People are saying, that's you?
Tragically no, this is on
the video of Kim Jong-Un.
And to be fair to Dudley Do-Right?
It was hilarious.
Him riding a horse?
Mmmh.
Okay.
Here's another one,
Kinda like how you celebrate pedophiles.
Ooh, this could go either way.
I told you.
I don't know, Kim Jong
he's a monster probably,
but I'm gonna go with you.
No.
This is of Kim Jong-Un.
Again don't know this
is from W. Grinstead.
Don't know what he's referring
to, but I'm sure it's bad.
The more horse?
This video is insane.
You're actively viewership because people
are just watching this video now.
This is more entertainment.
He's like a male shoot.
Male version of Amy Schumer, awesome.
Kim Jong-Un don't need anymore.
(Chuckling)
It was Kim Jong-Un.
Kim Jong-Un leather speech.
Here's the last question.
This is a tough one.
Okay.
Look for how you answer it.
Judging by all of the
other previous responses,
I will not do well.
He is so funny?
He is also the definition
of a butter face?
I don't know who that applies to.
Who is it?
Both you and Kim Jong-Un hot angles,
big round angle he's got.
Kim Jong-Un
you're being timed.
My girlfriend says you are
very hot when you were blonde.
Wow, I do remember that
time when Cantu was trying
to sort of test the waters to see
if she could leave you for me.
But unfortunately no,
that comment was about me.
Somebody thinks on their face.
So offensive, but I accept
it because have body
than a hot base.
So that's it Moses, I
think you've got maybe two
correctly out of all of them.
And you didn't really quick about it.